a reaction to the Game of Thrones series
finale part two is a Fisher most
disliked Game of Thrones video oh boy
it's it's almost neck and neck it's fun
it's funny it's funny because like it's
come full circle I 90 percent like a
ratio for video now it's hello there
reject nation I'm Greg Alba we are going
to do a season a tour view of Game of
Thrones now that we've settled in at
patreon one of our top of war tiers is
whatever video requests we must do put
up on youtubes and Mikael linden he
requested this which I'm glad he did
because honestly I wasn't polite
I don't know if you thought we were I
didn't think we were gonna do a review
of the season I thought like if anyone
really wants to know our opinion they
can just go to the reactions because we
reviewed the episodes right afterwards
but what I also know is with something
like as opposed to doing a trailer
reaction with something like Game of
Thrones or even coming out of a movie
right away sometimes some some opinions
change some opinions you've got like you
know more negative or you go more
positive anytime you have time to sit
and reflect on something and sort of
ruminate on the events of the show and
and feel your feelings too about it
because every one of these is an
emotional experience I think like one of
one of the parts of our of our work that
I don't love as much actually as
instantaneously reviewing things kind of
for that reason because time reactions
are done people Jon does not like this
set up
Game of Thrones where it is so dense and
there is so much riding on it is a lot
of like pressure in a way to be like
okay now I have to know exactly how I
feel and I have to review it you know on
the spot yes and it's not bad it's just
a different way to do it so yeah now
that we've had a couple days anyway or a
day we finished this less than 24 hours
ago every night every every half day
feels like two days yes after after
watching it out yeah I was disappointed
by the series finale but I do want to
make this really clear I still think I
put out a tweet about this Twitter is
the best place to state any opinion I
put out a tweet about this and I think
that even though I was you know the last
half of season 8 was where most of my
issues actually came into play and even
though the series finale was overall
disappointing for me and there's some
things I want to clarify about things we
said things that obviously got
miscommunicated I still think Game of
Thrones is one of the best shows of all
time I I would have a very difficult
time not saying that because there are
so many love season 7 of season sevens
were the opinion of things getting rush
started coming into play however I
really didn't love that season and I
think all the seasons leading into it or
just like you at least have almost in
unison six great seasons which is very
diff bad that people keep comparing like
which finale did it better Breaking Bad
was five seasons and Game of Thrones six
seasons of it were just like unanimously
amazing and I love Season seven so I
still think that this is one of the best
shows ever and even what they
accomplished here with season 8 on
everything on a technical say they
pretty much were prepping us for they
wanted this to feel like a movie this
season and I think from a production
quality standpoint from cinematography
visuals music a water bottle and a
Starbucks I still think that it's one of
the best-looking shows and I can't
stress this enough the performances here
are great as much as the issues have
seemed to come into play with the
writing of this season
overall storytelling I think the
performances were excellent everyone
keeps talking about you know Peter
Dinklage you know we gotta give him
another Emmy we got to give another Emmy
I think Emilia Clarke nailed it nailed
it you guys watching Netflix [ __ ]
yeah I think Emilia Clarke was perfect
in that in this season this is the most
I've enjoyed her performance I think
absolutely because more than just you
know her awesome badass lines that she
would have or very specific intimate
scenes so much of her role this season
had relied primarily on body language I
think well for a lot of the character
beats yeah yeah because it is so plot
heavy this season a lot of things pass
in looks and in lingering shots on
emotion and stuff especially in the last
episode like you look at the scene where
she's looking at the Iron Throne that's
all on her face no well the episode
before the bell yeah
the episode before the bells the bells
was the previous episode this was called
know I've seen the episode before the
bells oh yeah for it's for I'm glad work
you I'm glad we're podcasting this
really keep all this before the bells I
don't know what that one was called last
of the starts maybe but it doesn't
matter right episode four when Masson
day is killed didn't the look Daenerys
Gibbs were you're watching this like
she's starting to crack here that has
been like getting memes but no one's
really making fun of her you know and
that moment it's like an iconic image to
me now of just her staring in fury but
right before it smashes to black it's
little things like that like her
performance there were I just I really
think she deserves an Emmy nomination at
least for this season I mean like I said
I've often had I've often enjoyed the
character of Daenerys more than I've
enjoyed Emilia Clarke's performances
really but this season yeah I thought
she really stepped up a lot and this
season really does rest heavily upon her
and her character turns
you know that I mean for better for
worse where Danny ends up I'm sure is a
very visceral thing for a lot of people
there's people name their kids after you
know like yeah and and and for however
the writing handled it I thought she
brought a ton to it and the things that
were successful I think across the board
you know saying like thanks like you
said in in to the actors as well as all
of the you know physical elements of the
show like they all really do come
together to make some great moments even
if the season overall isn't what
everybody hopes you know well where they
were this season you know what it kind
of feels like to me I first off a lot of
people I've heard say this that if they
had just released season seven and eight
back-to-back and called like this Part B
I've heard a few people tell me that and
that no one will be complaining and I
don't agree with that I think there are
very different seasons is I think people
are drawing that comparison because of
what Breaking Bad did and how much they
stuck the landing on their own show and
I also don't think it's fair to compare
it's comparing that show I'm like it's
such a different show it's characters
different world and tires like it
doesn't make sense to compare them like
if you're trying to just compare one
good show to a different good show like
yeah and debate is going but with that
in mind Breaking Bad's Part A Part B
really does feel that way because they
shot it back to back and then Part B
picks up moments after a part like
moments out where here you at least got
a little bit of a time jump with them
walking into Winterfell at the beginning
of this season and what's interesting to
me about this specific season is the
approach I feel like a lot of opinions
are coming into play also based off of
knowledge leading into this of how
they're going to approach this season
because it I know this this wasn't the
case it kind of felt this way to me and
tell me if you disagree and I won't
argue with you for it I'll just be like
okay
it kind of felt like season seven the
show got canceled and then what they did
was it had a huge following and it
became this massive cult following and
actually it was like we got to renew
this you know what it didn't get to end
so we're gonna give you guys more money
to do six more episodes to wrap your
story huh see if that was the case if
that was this let's say that was the
story people would be much more for gigs
exactly right I thought we weren't gonna
get our characters endings yes we got it
yeah
instead of having what HBO apparently
wanted to be ten seasons being cut down
to seven as though somebody gave them it
definitely has that air about it yeah it
took a little longer to make yeah and
even that feels like okay there was a
gap because the show got canceled for a
little yeah like yeah it definitely has
that I feel like people would be much
leaner oh yeah I mean if you guys are
watching this review most like we've
seen our reactions to this I would I
would rank the episodes like this and
already here's where you know the
countless dislikes how would rank this
episode I I really like the Battle of
Winterfell that's my favorite episode
yeah okay I think each one of these
episodes has their own problems in terms
of whole game of Thrones world
storytelling each one of these right
except for maybe episode episode ones
the least problematic because it's just
people going hey see Episode one I put
at the bottom not because I actually
thought it was bad I actually liked that
episode it's just the most disposable
for me yeah you need like three of those
scenes really like episode two so I
would say the Battle of Winterfell
whatever that so it was called episode
two I really liked a lot of loved
episode two I think that that episode
brought me to like some heavy tears
again
the most character heavy yeah yeah so I
want to go buy these episodes in terms
of ranking and why and then I actually
would I would say the bells because of
the production
I know that's the the the worst reviewed
episode in Game of Thrones history I
think I got a lot right I know we we
kind of complained a lot but I couldn't
help but be enamored by the visual
spectacle there right and then I would
say episode 4 then the series finale and
then one even though the series finale
was the most disappointing out of all
the episodes to me easily episode ones
the one run like they recapped a lot in
genre to Dragon and there was no no one
reacted john tells her he's the king
he's the rightful heir we really came
into play in the season yeah I feel like
I would rank him roughly the same way I
mean I would put the Battle of
Winterfell in the second episode
definitely in the top two for me like
honestly the finale would be just like a
middle I would put in three or four
because I didn't hate it I would
probably oh you prefer go or the other
ones I don't hate it I like I like
episode 4 probably less than episode 6
for certain you know reasons and yeah
episode 1 is the same thing where it's
like I like that episode but yeah it's
it's mostly because it's been 2 years
and we got to remember who's getting
back and you know yes what the stakes
are so yeah it's like I would put that
and and yeah the bells in the middle
because the bells is an episode I find
to be arguably the most problematic in
terms of just like whoa these choices
but at the same time it is such a well
rendered piece of filmmaking
yeah you know and it like I like I said
if it had better lead-in yeah it would
have worked perfect yeah you could have
kept that episode pretty much the same
like but if you just had better lead-in
to Daenerys is switch yeah like leading
into that it would have been fine yeah
it's like to recap the things I've said
in every reaction pretty much it's like
I don't hate all of the choices this
season has made and I think that every
episode like for the most part maybe
perhaps sans episode for every episode
has been an experience to watch that I
got really caught up in emotionally
still so like as effective
filmmaking yeah like there is so much to
appreciate and I do think that where
things end up while there are things
that get dropped and things that are
just plain inexplicable things that are
unsatisfying there are some things that
I find at least conceptually interesting
in a way that yeah in an expanded season
or in a show that took its time a little
bit more I could see myself being better
on board with than having to you know
fill in the blanks myself yeah yeah to
me it's just more about how we got there
and what we did but we didn't see the
house cuz yeah it's it's that checklist
thing of like okay we know where the
characters need to go so we're not gonna
really spend any time with them and
really see the emotion yeah I mean we've
beat this point to death already as I'm
sure as many many many people have as
well is that the the season does is
really hampered this isn't this seems to
be a general consent for people who like
it like really were satisfied is that
the the season is hampered by the fact
that it's so much less episodes and that
there's a lot to wrap up so you don't
get time to really live with anything
any anything new that occurs or any
twists that happens or any big change it
happens I'm gonna live in it like even
Daenerys changes and then 15-20 minutes
later the next episodes I feel like you
can boil it down to just that it's it's
you know you know pretty much the main
they really cut down on character
moments they gave us a whole lot of them
really impressive spectacle and they you
know got the plot where they felt it
needed to go cuz I think there are I
think majore think there are choices
just plain and simple that people will
have issues with Aria kills the night
King brand being the king you know like
there's there's choices that are Circe's
no matter how many no matter how many
episode you could use this 24 episodes
and if you made those choices I feel
like those would still be controversial
those like choices like that but for the
most part majority of the things that
went down were fine in terms of the
idea in terms of the concept behind it
it really is just the the execution of
it that hampered it a little bit like
okay this whole thing I want to clear it
I want to take some clear up something
about the series finale of what we were
saying cuz I didn't read any of the
comments I have it
I've weren't any a comment so in the
game throws videos since the first
episode right maybe we were telling me
that what some of the context was of
some of the content of the comments and
people seem to be reacting to when we
were really harping on the episode of
the series finale of drogon not killing
John or even it seemed like he's
attempting to kill John oh we cool with
that he's like attempting to kill John
or if or if you like fires that he
doesn't see there's a lot of things that
just and then and some people seem to
heavily justify it and maybe you're
right
with fandoms such as Game of Thrones
there usually seems to be no middle
ground it seems to either be you hate
the whole damn thing and it's the worst
show ever - I love it and I can overly
justify everything like it seems to be
like these like where's the middle 40s
I'm generally in the middle because I
really like the first it's funny because
that with this season I remember people
going after the second episode of even
though people really like the second
episode that we need to sort of hurry
[ __ ] up really that's six episodes left
anything is going yeah every time some
four it's like we're going too fast you
realize in an extra twenty minutes on
three episodes is not necessary do all
the legwork you need it so with John and
Rogan right yeah
what were some of the defense's that you
were hearing I mean obviously the first
one that came to mind even when I was
saying it was that John is Targaryen and
rogue on senses that Orson yeah that's
one of I feel like we both said it in
the video maybe or at least I had the
thought I was like well I don't know
maybe drogon can sense that Danny's
being corrupted by the thrown inand she
had to die yeah and some people also
made that point so yeah it's basically
those two points guys there
drogon is really smart is what both of
them are because there is a lie majora
says that dragons are as smart as humans
or someone or something like that which
a I mean I could I there's an innocence
show if they I just didn't buy it for
what they've shown me over time like
drogon has been staring John down the
whole season there was a scene right
before he walked in and when he were
here I it's a beautiful shot where he
rises out of the snow drogon and he just
like and like drogon has yeah it's yeah
before any things happen so he's like
okay you can go yeah yeah but you know
even before it's like drug on has
incinerated of several of her close
advisers and stuff like that so like
yeah in that moment I just didn't didn't
bring authentic to see I think you know
if there's yeah they just would have
needed to have built up to that or
explained it you know who knows like I
know the common thing and doing reviews
is saying you owe expositional dialogue
that's it's not black and white X is
some exposition you catch Kurt you a
long way and something like the
economics of yeah I would rather them
give me an expositional piece of
dialogue that at least justifies that
moment better than it says to me oh well
they just needed to not have because you
know what that moments led to a lot of
people theorizing why he didn't do it
yeah yeah so no one has a clear-cut
answer on it but the problem with now is
like the theories aren't gonna go
anywhere because it's the last episode
the shows that you see some people have
said that drogon he did he was trying to
but he couldn't because so he fired his
gun in the air and then some people say
oh he he knew the thing about the throne
and yada yada yada
yeah but why okay yeah but I'm like but
why would he if he had all these
thoughts of like this this whole pursuit
of the throne and look what it's done to
Danny mom's getting weird what's gone
crazy like but you're you're the dragon
murder yeah she actually didn't do any
of it it was all you buddy about you you
are not a gun yeah pull some here firing
like if that's if drogon is this
character now who's more than just a
mindless dragon who follows mommy and is
now a character who makes decisions like
that that's not it's not it's just it's
story center wise it's not there it's
not literally one of those times where
you plug a plot hole it's like plugging
a hole in a boat and then another hole
yeah because you plug that hole it's
like that that's what that's like and
the problem is this season leaves just
way too much room for a lot of this kind
of debate specifically yeah it's not a
hundred percent clear that it's
impossible but it's also not made clear
at all how it's possible yeah exactly
exactly I'm like either one of us could
be right honestly at that point if you
completely disagree I'm like well
honestly you don't really have enough I
could tell you George RR Martin's says
that the only one who won't be killed by
fire are the Targaryen heiress I believe
he didn't say that just because you're a
Targaryen doesn't mean all of them are
invincible it's just Danny yeah correct
us if we're wrong but I yeah but they're
Monica why dendro but I'm trying to bite
him they're just it's just like some
force field shield that just doesn't
allow him to bite him or something you
know what I mean it's things like this
that just felt even when you're making
drogon at that moment you kind of made
rogue on a full character because he's
like I said before he's just mindless
dragon who he follows mommy's orders
right and in that moment he made a
political decision I've seen enough it's
still what yeah to me that I didn't get
enough from them and that was what we're
saying I was I'm bringing this point up
not because people I think took that as
we wanted Jon Snow to die because we
don't like Jon Snow or something like
that what I'm like that's not the case
for me I just felt that in that moment
there should have been more him at least
attempting to kill Jon un ring true yeah
that's basically it it's not because I
hate Jon Snow it's because I just don't
agree with how that scene went down and
it's because that like killing Jon in
that moment could have given some kind
of poignant and some kind of tragic I
also would have loved it
to the whole thing yeah because if he
you know it's like no one will know the
sacrifice that he made no one will know
that he stopped perhaps the mad Queen
for those who are not on board with
Danny because some people out there
still on board with Danny but but yeah
that could have been a poetic ending for
him yeah really so that's also it's like
oh not only did you make not that
interesting of a choice but you also
made a choice that's making me ask a lot
of questions yes I want to go back I'm
gonna do a big jump here I want to go
back I just like some highlights of
whatever they loved see sowed three it's
not called the Battle of Winterfell
whatever that episode I understand the
complaints that people had about Knight
King and see I'm I'm on the side of this
story of the audience who sort of feels
like wasn't he always just kind of just
that what he was portrayed as you know
it's like we wanted to know more in the
end the show is that is what developed
the night came from I understand the
night king is not in the books and so
he's always just sort of been this
character that doesn't really have depth
and maybe it's the case where they said
we need to save stuff for prequel what I
have liked to have no more sure did I
really did I the thing is for me I
didn't really care to know more I know a
lot of people did though so I understand
that and I know a lot of people thought
that there should have been a cool or
fine art adjust like how the folks you
sneak up on him and she kills him the
thing though for me is as much as like
there's problematic questions that erupt
from a lot of how things what the
outcome was after that episode that Aria
kills a night king moment is my favorite
moment out of this entire season it's a
controversial moment yeah and none of my
love for it comes from the controversy
my love for it comes from how well
executed that moment is because in that
moment I don't think anyone's thinking
should go biking you know that's not the
reaction anyone happen
yeah they're all just so enamored by
them I think the issues that people
thought about that came post watching it
not you're watching it and you know it's
gonna happen and now you're annoyed you
know what I mean well cuz in that moment
you just I think that moment is super
effective cuz we all just get caught up
in this anybody somebody the night king
has to die yeah and then you know you
have the combination of oh is he gonna
kill her you know cuz it's it's it's a
perfect moment I love it I love watching
the reaction compilations for it and I
love watching the bar rate like the
reactions where they would play the show
at bars and you got a whole group like
it's always the same it's always the
same and I felt it too and you know
anyone who does reaction videos will let
you will tell you that a lot of times
they could feel what's about to come out
of them and that moment really hit me oh
when I was actually kind of glad a
camera was recording yeah because there
was a conflict that we had before
filming this of do we just want to enjoy
this last season or do we actually want
to make videos out of this and I was
glad there's a camera there because I
have the exact reaction everyone else
had and I and it's when she first shows
up and everyone goes yeah and then she
gets carded like then she drops a knife
and no you don't cheer yet you're like
oh then once she stabs perfectly with
the visual moment everyone has the same
reaction going you're by yourself or
with you're in a bar for a reason
they've named Nate on a directing level
they nailed that moment and I never like
for me when I when I when you watch our
react I freaked out I had to I had to
like get out of my body for like a
couple seconds into it because I was
like whoa
and I mean yeah it like you know to be
completely honest you're not always a
hundred percent happy to have a camera
pointed at you during this kind of show
but that really was a moment where yeah
it's like I'm really glad like as a
memory because then yeah magical about
Game of Thrones especially is that there
aren't that many shows where you can
feel like you brought up the people in
the bar like those kinds of reaction
videos and I feel like there are a few
shows that will draw people to community
that particular way where it's like even
if you're not at a bar watching the show
even if you're not at a game of Thrones
party which I like on Instagram stories
I can't tell you how many Sundays I've
seen who's got a watch party going you
know that aspect of community is
something where yeah I'm like I'm so
glad I have that memory on tape yeah cuz
that episode too even if you know
whatever satisfaction it brought to the
season overall that episode of TV was
such magic to watch and I loved the way
they shot it I know there's a lot you
actually [ __ ] her stream along and
maybe it's in the reaction highlights we
had to be like - we can't see anything
can you turn off some of these and I
thought it was like maybe there's our TV
maze because we have lights on though we
can't see what's going on but then then
when we check online and hear a bunch of
people the comedy joke was that is that
most people COO like what the hell
happened in episodes but from from a
point of view perspective of that moment
of where those characters at in war in
battle I thought that was a brilliant
choice I liked that you that you kind of
have to make out what's going on you
know because of the you puts you sort of
in the conditions that are experiencing
whereas like the White Walkers that's
not an issue for them and maybe the
people who live in the north that's not
an issue for them but for a lot of them
like that's how scary and chaotic it was
it's pitch black
it's dark I thought it was a harrowing
that that one just I thought it was such
an effective episode you know what I
mean I thought like the mood really
nailed it I think if anything this
season overall did well it's just
putting you in those situations like
across the season I always really felt
like I was
even in the more mellow just characters
talking moments is very intimate and a
very striking visual season that that
wants you to be caught up in the action
very much you know that's not
unproblematic but it is the bells does
that as much as the turn has been in
like very divisive for people and to
clarify once again because you always
had a really refined these things I when
we did their reaction when the credits
were rolling we were all saying like
she's probably gonna go mad Queen Anne's
episode right like we all just saw it
coming that she that we had a feeling
she would go mad Queen and a lot of us
did and like I said a lot of it is about
like does it earn it does it properly
build into it because it was about was
it like the episode before or just
seemed like they were kind of rushing
like okay now we really got a full-blown
I really think this episode some people
have different opinions about this some
people think that four people have
issues with the lack of episode some
people think that you just needed ten
episodes twelve some people think a
whole other season I'm in the camp that
thinks you just needed about 10 to 12
episodes and it would have been fine you
could have let all these choices at
least breathe or live for one full
episode you know each one of the major
choices varies everyone learning about
John's true heritage Danny being ruler
would have been good for like at least
two to three episodes you know after
destroying Kings like get any more time
with Cersei all these things would have
I feel like yeah six ten twelve episodes
would have been fine you know exactly
what would have been perfect but I think
that certainly would have been better
especially in the way that the last
couple of seasons have pared down the
focus of characters that were really
following because I think that's kind of
one of the aspects in which the show has
changed is we're not we're just not
focusing on as many things anymore so
yeah you know like 10 to 12 episodes or
something like that just to yeah it's
and I feel like I've heard people say
that a lot about season eight is that I
don't hate everything they chose to do
it's as little as we've said multiple
times it's just how they got there and
so yeah having some moments for us to
yeah live with the characters and have
some of the moral quandary is because
the other thing that I used to really
appreciate in previous seasons was the
debate of it because the thing
is Tyrians decision-making is another
big gripe about this season and I agree
with that for sure you know in the night
Peter Dinklage is so great he's still
turning there's still great the writing
of some of his decision making seemed
out of character to be a little smarter
I think that like the whole thing with
the Crips seems to be a big thing you
know Peter Dinklage's commented on that
and see me not happy with that choice of
what they did with this character their
thing I think Peter Dinklage felt his
character would have been smart enough
to be aware of that yeah yeah I mean you
as audience members we're all oh yeah
but I mean my my question that was like
how maybe this is established how well
would Tyrion know the rules of being
able to resurrect the dead because there
was a part of my brain that was even
going well maybe it's that they have to
kill it's like whoever they kill and
then they can resurrect them well I
can't remember who knows what because I
know that the way it works is that the
White Walkers can raise White's and then
the whites are chained to the white
Walker so if you kill the white Walker
who sired the whites they'll all die
yeah if you just kill one white that's
just one zombies so like yeah I feel
like somebody at some point figures that
out or whatever I did but you know yeah
I don't know whose information got where
yeah so it was the original point
remaining about tearing oh you know
something about decision making but even
so yeah it's like the characters can
make bad decisions but the thing is when
you have an accelerated plot that is
mostly yeah now focusing more on the
plot than on why the characters are
making the plot happen and stuff like
that it's easy I think for things to get
a little sloppy and come across a little
silly or a little dumb you know it's
like if we had maybe seen some of the
thought processes that and and you know
kind of gotten caught up in the either
strategic or moral dilemmas that could
have led to some of these poor decisions
you know that could have been better or
just better decisions in general I don't
know it's like they had two years to
make this but at the same time something
about the character choices feels
very erratic in the season in a way that
feels rushed and I don't understand
quite how that would have happened is
rush and and then on the flip side when
the show decides to slow down people
complain but you know rushed in the way
leg leg leg they only had a small amount
of time to actually write it yeah like
not even just that it's taken oh okay
yeah I find it funny how it's like a lot
of people have complained in the series
finale of holstein dedicated to Tyrion
putting in you know chairs and then like
man he's really walking down the post
effects of destroy in King's Landing for
a long time and like people come and
earlier seasons of Game of Thrones we
wouldn't have but because the series
finale we're like come on we got to do
an explorer and wrap us up it's it's put
Game of Thrones got put in this weird
position that when it wants to slow down
people feel like we need to hurry this
up and then when it goes too fast
people feel like vinius slow down the
show memorably the real solution was
just more episodes that was the only
solution they had yeah and again I've
heard this fact that the you know the
HBO wanted ten seasons and the show
runners were wanted to do seven or
something like that and it's just weird
how it always just comes back down to -
oh yes like if we had just took a little
more time I like Masson Days death would
have been more impactful if she got she
was a little bit after if she got to be
more of a character may even spend more
time with her in grey worm I don't care
if you build it up and being like ah
she's gonna die this season it would
still would have been more effective
yeah it seemed like she was used as a
plot device to fuel Daenerys that's the
thing with some of these choices that I
get a little bit irked by well I think
that everyone does a stellar per one
does a stellar performance hear things
like bran I love the moment when she's
knighted I like that would you watch our
reaction man eyeball like yeah I was so
moved by that scene because I loved that
character and then it sort of felt like
her character was sort of just used to
support and Jaime's journey
and not her own journey yeah that's why
I think that's a big part of what
changed is that earlier on in the show
it felt like every character had their
own journey and maybe we spent more time
on the more focal characters but now it
seems like a lot of our side characters
have been morphed into okay it's like
Varys Ferris used to have plot lines now
very he's a foil for Danny
yeah and Tyrion he's kind of a foil and
also her advisor and then Jon he's a
foil for Danny now he's also got his own
plot line their foils free yeah you know
yeah just characters get boiled down to
okay now yeah she's a part of Jamie's
play Varys was one too word Oh he learns
next episode he's dead Daenerys does
King's Landing blows it up she's dead
the next step like this is also fast
Jamie leaves he gets like half hour to
forty minutes was pretty time in total
over the course of two episodes reunites
Jamie Jamie reassess Cersei goes back in
this whole arc and dies
Cersei it's like I feel like I can count
there's like the amount of screen time
yeah barely in this season like it's I'm
fascinated by this season and a weird
see the weird the reason I hate this but
really quick though you do make a great
point about how it seems like a lot of
our sideline characters like the people
who are just generally supporting
characters because you know who your
main characters are in the show the
supporting characters seem to just
primarily be there like okay we can all
some of these people okay you guys we
need your deaths at or they're primarily
used for supporting the main characters
now instead of having their own
individual journeys that's a great point
well that's another reason why deaths
used to feel more shocking to is even if
they didn't like you remember when like
Oberyn Martell died and he goes like ah
he's gouging like skull beat in like
that was still like a shocking death
even though he wasn't like a main main
main main character and like that's
partly because we get to know and spend
time with all the characters to some
degree and yeah they're just not doing
that anymore was it's like bran
everybody brought bran this season
brought had two scenes he came beginning
to be like Cersei wants me to kill the
both of you and I'm gonna make a deal
okay they came in for our he was doing
it with the chicks the prostitutes okay
yeah and and then you know so it's like
okay you're sitting up some stakes for
Jamie into your
and then that never pays off and then he
comes back at the end to just you know
kind of bulk up carians story a little
bit you know there's a lack of payoffs
here you know I personally loved the
show even even though it's a short
season
I loved it more when it was slowed down
I've the second episode to me was
beautifully done I loved just maybe it
wasn't a political driven episode but it
was a very much just coming that seemed
to be at that point where I wanted the
show to sort of get to of politics don't
matter right now what matters is
survival you know and showing what life
is like for these people on the verge of
that battle yeah well they're not just
talking politics that's great like that
is to me one of the higher points of the
season yeah because it is one of the few
times we really get to spend some actual
time with our characters and have some
emotional storytelling yeah and like the
whole thing with John being a Targaryen
seemed to be a like they morphed it into
a plot device to fuel Dany more like
once you drop that in once he told her
but it's also like when he told her
that's because it got like when he told
her was like terrible time
Jon Snow is a character whose logic this
season kind of got on my nerves a little
bit I will say this though in terms of
series finale looking back on it I
thought it was pretty cool how the
Lannisters and the Starks are
essentially what kick starts this season
this series you know and they seem to
have always been sort of at war with
each other and then Tyrians the last
remaining lannister and then Jon Snow
while not in a you know like a
biological stark he is like have start
oh yeah yeah but no I got so used to the
whole Targaryen
[Laughter]
but having a bit Nonnie's on Ned Stark's
kid yeah but being the representation of
those and then sort of watching the
switch of positions die I don't know how
much the Benioff and Weiss put into this
thought process but looking into it I
thought it was neat of how that the Mad
King is killed by a stark as opposed to
you know like Jaime Lannister yeah and
Tyrion is essentially doing the net
start paying him like doing the right
thing standing up I'm not gonna I'm
probably gonna get beheaded you know I
like seeing that I thought that was
pretty neat but you know there were
there are things like just cuz you
sometimes I think the idea of surprise
and subvert expectations I think when
you try to go for that it can kind of
weaken your the impact and overall
storytelling and I feel like this season
kind of succumbed to that a little too
often yeah like trying to figure it out
still I think I like the whole brand
choice is something we can do we can
debate all day yeah
the for me it did open up some core some
questions that I was thinking about on
my own of like wait a minute
this brands like I was like dr. strange
where he can see possibilities like
possible outcomes or does he does he
just see the outcomes you see the
outcomes the past and the present coz he
kind of just sideline most of this yeah
and he was like like that's why I came
here I want to be king dude I'm like
wait you've let all this horrible stuff
happen you just let all these terrible
things go on and then now you're
supposed to be the saving grace that
there's that question stop them he just
has all the knowledge but if he has all
the knowledge why didn't he say anything
why don't you bring any of that up cuz
these things are gonna happen anyway see
that's what I mean you're many things
are in motion this is my king is coming
that's a real threat like what can but
would Daenerys know it well yeah that I
think's landing all those things that I
am curious about because that does open
up a plot hole where it's like yeah did
you have some kind of ambition here that
or or see like sometimes an open to
Angela at the same time if he just
busted he's like guys she's gonna go
crazy you're gonna go live in the woods
and I'm gonna be king like how would
that have gone over maybe well the thing
is he still like he still let all that
go down so he could be king
you know what I mean but you can you
still let all those
terrible things go down so he can
eventually be king yeah the thing is
you're drying your logical you're
drawing your own conclusions I'm drawing
my conclusions the show did not give us
the clue that's the that's issue like I
don't feel like we need to fight about
it I don't feel like how do you argue
about the thing is we're drawing our own
conclusions because the show because the
show is like giving us the conclusion
because the shows like I don't choose to
incorporate your view into my but I it's
a hundred percent yeah I'm like so like
the the more I think about it the more
problematic the brand choice becomes
even though I like that I think that of
everybody left he is the best person to
be king but but because that he's the
only buddy left he kind of his I love
them all wipe each other like that's how
I viewed it because it wasn't just me I
think that's a totally valid way to view
that the thing would brand that a you
got to understand I feel like generally
speaking he's not exactly a beloved
character I think generally I'm the odd
guy I really liked him this season I I
liked the performer I don't know any but
I liked the guy who played him ten years
ago this guy's learned the character I
like the guy who slays him I liked his
performance and how he handled it just
some things seem to be a little bit
inconsistent with how the road and plus
he doesn't really get screen time he
kind of seems a little even with the
whole because the whole idea of Bram
being built up was for showdown with my
king and that seemed lackluster in terms
of night king and brand and then he was
the bait but yeah like what do you cut
to him for that for he's gone he's there
to select Leon for those he's got like
30 minutes of screen time over the
course of three episodes then he's gone
and then he shows up and everyone at
this council is agreeing with the
prisoner and and and I don't do most
people know who branded like the most
people like get who bran is do they
understand who bran really is well you
know what I mean
again jury would have made sense oh I've
heard that brought up in terms of being
like a Baratheon like that would either
way my point with this is like we can
literally can argue about this but we
don't need to because I feel like the
show should've just done a better job of
laying this stuff out so that way we're
not just hearing a bunch of theories
about it for better for certainly better
and worse this season very much just
allows there room for the pro and and
negative argument to any nitpick you can
bring up really because some beg much
further extension a suspension of
disbelief than others but so many of
these things yeah you can just come up
with like a well and they're all yeah so
it's like that's the underlying problem
with this season ultimately is just that
there are so many of those vagaries and
holes that could have been fixed by
having more time yeah some stuff just
has nothing like REO with the horse I
didn't feel like that was really
supposed to have a payoff it was just
like okay she's a nice symbolic figure
they've spent a lot of time yeah really
I don't understand really the
significance of it other than you know
like the white horse is a symbol to
Google what a white horse means well a
pale horse is a symbol of death but like
you know she rides the pale horse out of
the city but then she's back in line
that is being a very significant plot
point as much as it's just like well you
gotta get out of this city as fast as
you can you're the only one left and
you've got a horse now so there you go
and then you'll regroup and walk back
yes I know it's it's honestly I don't
really give a [ __ ] about it to be honest
I don't really give a [ __ ] about the
worst thing I there are left their heads
though you know like we all thought the
Dothraki were dead the Dothraki show up
then they're all celebrating with
Daenerys who suddenly has her target oh
yeah you've always got their tail
we never see that that's the spin I want
is the people making all these clothes
and then we don't excite I feel like I
can probably draw my own conclusions
like well they're Dothraki you know
their Queens gone they don't really like
when wait when uh Drogo when Drogo died
they're like we don't follow you so when
they lose a leader they seem to just go
yeah so I keep the toughest I can draw
that conclusion I like for something
like that I can draw on past episodes
ago like well if you think about it
here's what they did before
so this makes sense if we just don't get
an answer to it but you know there's
there to me like time jumps it can be
frustrating bad or I don't make one one
direct comparison for a reason Breaking
Bad's last episode is a time jump if I'm
not mistaken right he's like that's when
he has hair again he has a beard it's
like the second or last episode of the
first episode over the last episode was
one of the two anyway there's a time
jump the thing is you get to live within
that time jump for a while so you can
feel the conclusion here you get a time
jump like a half-hour before it ends
it's not a setting so yeah it's it
that's that's when I really like out of
any of the episodes I felt rushed it was
it was the serious finale to me yeah
because you know like Jon killing
Daenerys I'm gonna prom with that
but you know there are things that I
think they should have brought up the
whole thing with John being Targaryen so
you just get dropped like it got dropped
and especially for the under competition
like why did the unsullied just let
Tyrion live why they keep him prisoner
I'm why do they keep John prisoner did
John just go I see am i from knowing
John Snow I can go Jon Snow probably
told the truth even though we didn't
need to have didn't have to you've been
like she took off like he could have
just said that yeah but knowing the
character of Jon Snow I'm like he
probably told them the truth that makes
sense but why are they letting him live
exactly like the biggest question mark
for me was the unsullied especially with
the way the gray were
turned with Daenerys to just be full-on
rage mode after a while like his
character felt really weird to me this
season and I honestly have no idea
I don't his care Joe if their I don't
remember if it's established that there
are people who just cannot think unless
they have a queen or something but a
great words shift did not bother me a
lot of people feel that sentiment with
you though a lot of people do gray
worship does not bother me because if
you look at grey worm whose whole
generals are cut off and that's you knew
this guy generals cut off and he's just
a [ __ ] fighter his whole life he
murders right he's always been a strict
emotional murderer yeah and then he
finds love and then she is beheaded it
before his eyes his switch to me I'm
like no I get it said that dude oh yeah
look at who he was I think the issue oh
I think why is because you barely hang
it
yeah you know great was that when I
could unless like opposed to but I still
get it cuz I'm like yeah you barely
spent time with grey woman this guy you
know if it started to feel to me more
like again support for Daenerys rather
than grey worm having his own story you
know yeah and the thing the thing that's
interesting to me about this season is
that idea of the subversion of
expectations cuz a lot of things don't
go exactly the way you're expecting them
to and and I know that that's upsetting
to a lot of people and I do logically
agree it's like there are so many things
that just don't yeah it's like John
being a Targaryen to me that what comes
across it's funny I don't know what the
intent is and I've heard the criticism a
couple times on just other shows you
know that I've listened to other
discussions that Benioff and Weiss are
not as much about the mystical side of
the show they want to get past that
stuff to the political stuff why they
put it in yeah and so I I can stay if
that is true because that they put the
knight King in the show but I am unless
that was their way of making the
mystical physical so they could get rid
of it really easily or something but
I don't know like John's heritage just
became a way like I didn't know if the
point maybe was to take that and go okay
this was the thing that seemed too
mystical like it should have some kind
of magic payoff but really what it did
was it just made a mess out of
everything which isn't I guess
satisfying but like it is interesting to
me in a way and it's like Circe's hole
it's like Circe's treatment this season
I 100 percent of Creek was not
satisfying in any emotional kind of way
however I do think it's kind of
interesting that at the end of it all
when it all came down to it her money
was not where her mouth was and then she
does die this really pitiful horrible
death and and like yeah and a season
that would have spent any time with
anybody that still could have been
interesting in a way yeah it's just yeah
it's so I'm sitting here going is that a
subversion of expectations or is it like
this whole season to me is felt like
whatever worked if we hung out with
Cersei well dad but this season has felt
like there are a million different
timelines for how Game of Thrones could
have ended and we just happen to get
this one but yeah another timeline it's
all different ending you know for a show
that started becoming pretty predictable
like I don't think anyone saw the whole
bran think I mean some people did some
people yeah I can't say that some people
saw that coming yeah some people saw him
at least having a big significance
coming yes yes
yeah but but for sure that for became
more predictable than a usual Game of
Thrones yeah even for someone like
myself who sucks at predicting just
anything with Game of Thrones I kind of
was like I sort of wish they did the the
route that we all thought it would take
hair where you have the night king they
get that out of the way most people are
killed and now they have to go up
against Cersei like and then you make
that the political drama like I'm like
that kinda would've been content with
that but instead it was like first three
episodes all about the night king next
next one
Cersei then while we're dealing with
Cersei we're gonna take away the focus
of Cersei and put it all into Narus
going crazy you know
and then BAM we're gonna kill off the
narrative and we got Brandon yeah it's
so rapid it's focused point
not on I think a lot of the focus was
off in terms of where they were
specifically wanted this directed to EDD
do you have it I mean by that yeah like
I think with season seven that was
pretty clear what was going on it was
season seven like the main focus of it
was pretty clear to me of weeding to get
an army together because John knows
about the nightwalkers and we and all
that and we need to start letting people
not worry you know we need to build for
the doesn't nothing else matters right
now
that's the folk thats why i don't think
putting season seven is season seven a
and this is season SEBI does not work
because the focal points are very
different and then this focus point that
they just kept shifting so much like the
the main thing it was coming down to i
guess was who's gonna be the king was
the main focus but you know like it does
suffer from the fact that john killings
all that could have worked analyst yeah
I probably would have been able to let
that [ __ ] go with drogon not like having
an I'm not being clear to find only
nitpick of this episode of totally
different but the thing is you know you
do a time jump and normally it would
have been fascinating to see the
reactions of people Sansa being like
[Music]
this going around to everyone and
learning what's happening and John being
captured where we gonna do about John
they're gonna kill John we got a style
you're like things like wow I've been
gripping there are a lot of those
punches pull dude we don't get to see a
lot of people's reactions to a lot of
crucial information which is a bummer
like that's one thing they taught us in
film school that is stuck with me
forever is that people skimp on reaction
shots but in this season reaction scenes
of a kind you know and I think the tour
gear see the whole thing with John going
back to the Nights Watch first thought
they should have really established
there was a Night's Watch like I think a
lot of people didn't realize they're
still the Nights Watch not even John
Snow knew there was a Night's Watch
because the whole point is like what are
they watching point had to do with the
wall in the White Walkers what are they
watching right now you know so that
could have had an impact of that's kind
of ironic
as opposed to that's as auric yeah like
I didn't hate it but again it's just a
dinner it really it doesn't earn it
because there's not proper lead up or
build into it and also I think if you
had really settled the whole whatever it
doesn't have to be he becomes king but
have a big conversation about the whole
Targaryen issue with him being that that
you could have gone into it yeah if they
got to bring that secret out that was
the clue season six I mean the
cliffhangers they break through the wall
the with the oh yeah but the texture
yeah yeah the character cliffhanger is
that yeah yeah so that that needed to be
paid off and and to me this if a little
why a wrap-up I didn't hate it I mean I
liked the idea at least of John going
out and essentially becoming somebody's
in the comments like a wiling becoming
like the new Mance Rayder just being
yeah you know yeah being among the
wildlings you know charting new land him
along the wall and I and I like that
generally because he spent a lot of time
among them he's responsible for bringing
them together with them with him and
he's responsible for that and a big part
of his earlier journey was when he's a
spy for the Nights Watch but you could
see he's well led to him you know
befriending the wildlings was the fact
that he was a spy and he got a he really
felt he connected with them the thing in
my eek like his relationship with
Ygritte I felt way more for that in his
romance for with him and Danny even that
feels a little rushed never felt there I
didn't really feel any further
connection until really not until right
before he killed her that's when I
started feeling for him when he's like
crying and stuff I felt it Oh for the
most part a little but I was also pulled
out by would Danny be having this
conversation as a character right now
you know like that that pulled me I felt
and I could go back and watch the
episode and feel differently but at
least from the first viewing it felt
like Danny's character just sort of when
madness took over her I don't know she
started to become I don't know how to
describe it even just it seemed like
madness had taken hold and now she
just kind of in her own world yeah
because that whole thing it's like she
has that moment with him before the fire
where she kisses him and she I thought
she was like I can feel the lack of love
here so it will be fear yeah I thought
it was gonna be a tension scene and not
a tragedy romance scene and she's so
overjoyed it felt like just yeah she's
just drunk on that she's cracked yeah
she's fully cracked now yeah so yeah I
don't know I've never really felt their
love and and this season didn't make me
feel it and I thought that could have
been interesting I don't know like John
as a character this season I thought was
lackluster simply because they only gave
him mostly the same principle for lions
to say which is I don't want the throne
I am loyal to Danny you know stop
fighting and I don't know I think Sansa
her hurt her I liked her pain like I
mean the context of the choice of that I
really loved her being Queen like you
know she's Lady of Winterfell yeah like
I think that's great I loved I loved the
open-ended known and arias journey I I
really I really loved that choice almost
almost everyone's conclusion was you
know I could kind of put things to this
I'm not sure and I understand this is
the whole political vote in that moment
didn't feel like Game of Thrones to me
and he even makes them like big I forgot
I'm already forgetting with like the big
political decision he makes right there
in the moment yeah but baking changes
that I'm like they have flown well with
that but we got to end it yeah one of
those things that you can speculate pro
or con about I mean to me I took that
moment simply as yeah this doesn't feel
like Game of Thrones because I feel like
this just great he who never would have
made it to this place with these other
people like I believe that the the lords
and ladies who they gathered would
listen to a Tyrion had to say because
one of them is Sansa at the very least
you know like they they know and they
not in Danny's corner so I believe that
they might listen to Tyrion they all to
a degree or most of them to a degree
have experience with him my main issue
with that was was the grey worm side of
it where I was like I thought you would
have killed him immediately yeah so yeah
like I and as a choice I mean yeah
Tyrion I understand all the things to be
said against his character the one thing
coming from bran especially that I
appreciated was that he acknowledges yes
I have I have really made some terrible
choices over time and he made at least
in the bluntness of the writing a
character turn where I was like okay it
seems like you have reached the next
level of perspective to where you might
make a good hand of the king again but
yeah again as we've said about every
point it's not earned by the way they
handle it yeah yeah I think expect it
still to me one of the best shows ever
yeah I think spectacle was top not like
some just amazing iconic shots I think
that have formed from this season alone
yeah and I mean that's just dragging
stuff dance down because I didn't always
love it in the previous season but and
the shop like that shot just seems like
it's gonna be so famous with Daenerys
walking in the wings for me behind her
things like that and the music is the
best the show has ever been and the
visual effects palette I love there was
plenty I liked from the I like to me
most of my issues come in the last let's
see it was episode 4 when I felt like
things started to get really rushed
episode 5 was a little jarring but I
really liked the way I just loved the
way I got it I think it's if you're a
person who appreciates filmmaking you're
gonna really get a lot from episode of
five whether or not you agree with the
storytelling of it I think on the
technical cinematic scales you're just
like yeah I can't help but appreciate
that well yeah and in within the
highlights real feeling of the season
overall it just feels like a
particularly good highlight yeah you
know you still feel all the feelings I
mean if this was a revival last season
yeah people probably wouldn't be
complaining
yeah if this is like a revival thing but
because it's been a wait so I kind of do
wonder how this season will feel overall
come with a few weeks or now a few
months a few years from now will this be
looked at with more fondness it will be
more appreciated because I know right
now it's in but the I'll say it's a
definitely split yeah I I don't think
it's over like mainly positive and
mainly negative I think it's pretty
split on how people overall feel about
the way this this last season and let
alone the series finale oh yeah everyone
everybody wants a little something
different you know it's like even I'm
sitting here going you know what would I
have wanted from this season see I
didn't even think about what I would
have wanted I I judged every episode off
of what the only thing I wanted was a
proper payoff to the Targaryen situation
with John Bennett so that's the only
thing I wanted okay out of anything
everything else I just went off of what
the show gave this isn't doing what I
expected you know but you know in
hindsight I feel like we can all look
back and be like oh I wish they could
have done this or they could have done
that and you know it's like if it had
been my show I would have done you know
- I would have done an 8a and 8b five
episodes - each do five episodes on the
thing with the night king do five
episodes on the thing with the Iron
Throne and have those be their own
contained cool because then you can have
the second-to-last episode of each arc
be a battle and there you go
because I'm in the camp - worth oddly
beyond it's like a lot of this stuff
with the people ending up where they did
I thought was fine and I just would have
expanded upon the thing I would have
changed that the overall direction of
would have been the night king for me
actually perhaps the most disappointing
thing to me is not the the construction
of the night king stuff but just the
significance of it overall is the
biggest sort of nonplussed well it just
seems like that was kind of a big that
night king is a major example of that
yeah
then but that example you could apply to
a lot of situations in this for me
that's the most disappointing elements
that's the element I wanted to be oh no
a lot of things kind of just get dropped
a lot of its kind of just or something
big happens and but I yeah I tied them
especially so it comes to that yeah it's
like I for this season I I it's funny
for this season and the way it came out
it's perhaps my favorite element but for
the show overall I would have liked a
different storyline ending for him yeah
and for the White Walkers personally but
yeah I agree with that I I do I still
think that it deserves
I know metal alchemist remake I think
from a I think if you are someone who
really did like this season I actually
can't I wouldn't try to convince you
otherwise no I'd be like I don't do that
I'm not that guy let me find you and
explain to you bothers me do you have my
opinion this videos existence does not
mean that you need to have these pitches
you can't comment but don't go to art
like social media don't find worse I'm
having a conversation with you yeah but
what are your guys's overall thoughts on
a season 8 like we didn't want to just
go over episode by episode here you know
it was more like okay now that we've
seen the whole thing how do we feel
about it overall the sort of the
approach to this thanks McHale for
requesting this because it did allow for
some things to get clarified a lot of
things it's it's nice to dish on this
yeah it's fun this will be a show that's
been topic we talked about for a long
time and no B videos dropping about it
for weeks to go yeah comment subscribe
like and share
yeah I'll say this there are some things
that I'm not over all this point about
not like there are some things that I
personally wouldn't want to or pay us on
there's some things I know people get
annoyed by you know why didn't Arya do
any face stuff yeah yeah no there get
that I get I get if you're a No
upset by that because of the hole with
that all this senator she did do a few
things doing that but you know she
doesn't really do anything they're never
the face that's killed the night king so
whatever I mean if I'm looking back you
know it all change over time but just as
I'm sitting here a day after the finale
yeah I don't hate this season I don't
have any vitriol towards it I don't love
it necessarily yeah are there things I
would have changed sure but overall I am
sitting here feeling happy that we came
on this journey and at the very least
and yeah
even if I'm disappointed by the overall
handling I don't hate where the story
threads ended and though I don't love
the decision to mostly focus in on just
the story elements in the late seasons
you know to degree I'm not entirely
unsatisfied you know which is not a
glowing review but there is some
satisfying stuff there is some
incredible top-of-the-line filmmaking
here that you know that will never we
might not all share again the way we've
shared Game of Thrones yes and that to
me is really special and so like the
highs of this season still ring that
bell if if we weren't doing what we do
for a living I probably wouldn't feel as
relieved that this is over like you deal
with a lot like people is I'm just
watching a show anyway yeah I like like
I had to just choose not to read the
comments but people will still find a
way to get to my social media and send
me messages and just like get a life you
know hell you care if I have a
difference and they say like and cool
people be cruel and I know that you can
still be witness to that whether or not
you do what we do but I will miss the
idea of community of people gathering it
like bars and like you can see if like a
Netflix show we release yeah I don't get
online to check the hash tag of shows
people are talking about very often it's
like Game of Thrones yeah this is Game
of Thrones is like we live in a binge
watching age
and Game of Thrones was how are people
reacting to this episode not happy
wreckage this season yeah and I'm gonna
miss that and Game of Thrones came from
a time before there were like as many
shows and apps and services and like
there's a glut now yeah totally like
Game of Thrones was born in a time where
the landscape was changing but it's
certainly different than it was back
then
yeah so I'm gonna I think it's a it's a
monumental show I'm gonna miss it I
think everyone gay I don't think there
was whether or not you
you think the writing is bad or good ice
I wouldn't say they were lazy I can't
say that so you know it's like some of
course I think a lot of writing choices
could have been a lot stronger like do I
think that yes and I think if they chose
to cut the show down to seven season so
much there's thousands of people that
were kepis owed there is like like me
watched the the caravan the loot train
yeah and like the amount of departments
and things that all need to be operating
together is unfathomable
so yeah and if I said this office is an
incredible fleet so yeah it's amazing I
do I think a lot of characters are
better payoffs yes do I think some story
could have been better for sure but
great filming without this is a great
filmmaking season and I as the show as a
whole I would still say it's one of the
best of all time because too many
episodes to count that are incredible
anyway guys let us know what you think
where are things that you you pissed you
off or things that you loved how do you
feel about this season overall your
opinion share it you guys can subscribe
to reject nation click the notification
bell catchy gasps ooh